11 ابريل 2019 بما في ذلك حبسنا كرهائن
لديها طلبا لرضا سياسيه واخرى اقليميه
ودوليه ثبت الان انها العدو الاول للشعب
السوداني
والسلطه القائمه ولقواته المسلحه فهي من
تسببت في الحرب الدائره الان
ونفرغ تماما ما بين القائمين على تلك
السلطه ومؤسسات الدوله الوطنيه وفي
مقدمتها
قواتنا المسلحه التي تقاتل بشرف وبشجاعه
وبساله كالعدي بها دوما وندعو كل جماهير
شعبنا
وعضويتنا لمزيد من الالتفاف حولها
ومساندتها واستراح المبادرات التي تسند
دورها الوطني الذي تقوم به الان
جماهير شعبنا الوفيه
ظلنا كقيادات ثوره الانقاذ الوطني
بمحبسنا بكوبر
تحت تقاطع نيران المعرفه الدائره الان
لمده 9 ايام
نتشارك وبقيه نزلاء السين وصيانين تلك
الظروف الامنيه الاستثنائيه
وانعدام مقومات الحياه من انقطاع تام
للمياه والكهرباء والطعام والرعايه الصحيه
حتى للجرحى من جراء تساقط النيران وسط قوه
السجون والنزلاء والتي توفى من جرائها
العديد منهم وجرح عدد اخر
ومنفجار الاوضاع داخل السجن بخروج كل
النزلاء يوم الاحد 23 ابريل 2023 من السجن
عنوه
حتى خلاه تماما منه زلائكه
فيما عدا قله لا تتجاوز العشره
من قاده وضباط وافراد وبناء على طلب القوه
المتبقيه من قوه السجون تحركنا لموقع اخر
خارج السي
تحت حراسه محدوده لا تتعدى الثلاثه من تلك
القوه على امل ان تتحصل سلطات السجون على
امر القضائي بالافراج عنا حسب افادتها
خلال ذلك اليوم لنواجه مع جماهير شعبنا لا
تزور فيه وتحدياته والقيام معه بذات
الواجبات الوطنيه فلم تعد هناك سيون قائمه
ولا مقار لمباشره اجهزه ووكالات انفاز
القانون لمهامها
وهكذا في الانقياده ضريبتها والتزاماتها
ونفخر ونحمد الله كثيرا على تشربنا تماما
لقيم موروثات شعبنا التي يعبر عنها بالمثل
السمعه ولا طوله العمر واذا عدم صدور
الامر القضائي المستحق قانونا لاسباب غير
قانونيه
عنها لاحقا وفي ظل تسارع وتتابع الاحداث
وازدياد حته الاشتباكات وتعاظم النذر
والمخاطر من حولنا وفي ظل انشغال السلطات
الاخرى بمهامها في اداره المعركه الوطنيه
الان القائمه فقد اتخذنا قرارا الخاص بنا
بان نتحمل المسؤوليتنا في حمايه انفسنا
بانفسنا وجاهزون للوصول امام السلطه
القضائيه متى ما تمكنت من القيام بمهامها
هي واجهزه هي واجهزتها المسانده لها ثقه
منا في سلامه موقفنا القانوني
ولنتقاسم مع شعبنا ادوارهم بطوليه
في الصبر والثبات والدفاع عن كيان دولته
من الاختطاف تحيه والتقدير والنصر لشعبنا
ولقواتهم المسلحه وهم يقاتلون في معركه
الكرامه الوطنيه
وندعو
منسوبي الدعم السريع المنحل
للانخراط مع اخوتهم في القوات المسلحه
وترك الالتزام تجاه قيادتهما الحاليه التي
ثبت انها تقودهم لمشروع شخصي واسري فقط
تقبل الله الشهداء
وشف الجرحى ورد المفقودين وواسل متضررين
والمتاثرين وما النصر الا صبر ساعه ينصره
الله فلا غالب لكم والله قالب على امره
احمد محمد هارون عن المعتقلين من قيادات
الانقاذ بسيم كوبر بتاريخ 25 ابريل عشرين
ثلاثه وعشرين لمتابعه المزيد
من الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس
التنبيهات